since Charlie and Dixie dee Emilio left
the hype house they've added Darian
Kisan Ches to their ranks but was this
really the best decision not only does
she have a reputation for being a bully
but Mackenzie Ziegler made some serious
accusations against her if they're true
no wonder so many fans are calling for
dari Janka to be kicked out of the hype
house as soon as possible there are some
stars who just seemed to thrive off
drama but Mackenzie Ziegler isn't
exactly one of them that's why it was so
surprising to hear that the Dance Moms
star was allegedly the target of
bullying and the accusations mackenzie
made go far beyond mere name-calling not
that we'd be cool with that either once
Charlie and Dixie to Emilio's said
goodbye to hype house we were excited to
see who would move in and take their
place
Daria ANCA Sanchez pops up to take one
of the open positions but as soon as she
appeared wearing hype house merch
Mackenzie fans stepped up to call her
out a video resurfaced of Mackenzie
sharing her thoughts on the newest hype
House member and they're not the best I
don't have a problem with daeryong qey
like I do she said da Rihanna is mean to
her calls her very mean words and hurts
her feelings obviously that's totally
unacceptable behavior but McKenzie also
alleged are young committed a serious
privacy breach by hacking into her
iCloud that might sound too crazy to be
true the back in 2015
TMZ reported that Mackenzie her former
dance instructor Abby Lee Miller and
other members of the Dance Moms cast
were back according to their sources
these hackers managed to find their way
into their cellphones iCloud's
emails and PayPal accounts apparently
poor McKenzie woke up to over 2,000
messages after her personal info was
shared online there was some speculation
guilty parties would start making
demands and possibly try to blackmail
Mackenzie and the other victims but
according to TMZ the affected cast
members hired a private investigator who
discovered the culprits were four young
women he dubbed the Mean Girls this
incident could be what Mackenzie is
referring to in the video when she said
her fans asked her why Danka has access
to her iCloud photos she said that
whoever managed to get into her iCloud
had an email address similar to danke x0
at gmail.com and then all of the sudden
Ariana seemed to have all
of her content Nessa barrettes who is no
stranger to scandal herself but she
could have actually confirmed our
yunkish ad site in an exchange posted on
the leaked fandoms underscore Instagram
account when told dar Janka can't be
trusted Nessa seems to respond exactly
why I said no when she asked to be a
part of my house we know Nessa is dating
sue a House member Josh Richards so is
it possible that danke was once trying
to join them instead of hype house the
same Instagram accounts that shared that
messaging exchange also shared one
allegedly with Dario ANCA herself it
looks like she asked them to stop
posting about her and accused them of
coming at her for days which to be fair
is true because leaked fandoms
underscore also shared text they claimed
were between danke and an unidentified
person according to this Daria Anka
admitted to having pics of mackynzie and
made fun of her looks although she also
said she deleted the photos she once had
so right about now you might be
wondering who is Dario ANCA anyway she
has over 300,000 followers on Instagram
but it seems like she only recently got
big when she was connected to hype house
in addition to showing off on social
media danke also makes videos on
tick-tock where she has over five
hundred thousand followers so far we all
know linking up with folks inside hype
house is a great way to get more clicks
but after what happened between Dario
ANCA and Mackenzie some fans don't think
she deserves the honor there are even
some people who suspect are Janka used
pictures she got from McKinsey
to establish herself on Instagram rack
up a bunch of fans and then deleted them
later on there's even a change.org
petition to get her kicked out of the
hype house and thousands of people
already have signed it even her fellow
tick-tock users might be turning on her
at this point
Dixie died Emilio deleted a picture of
them from her Instagram account and
she's either been unfollowed or not
followed at all by Charlie died Emilio
Nessa barrettes
Jaden host ler and Addison Rea just to
name a few for the other members of the
hype house their official Instagram
account stopped following anyone shortly
after charlie and Dixie left maybe
they're making some more changes around
the mansion if daeryong cos trying to do
damage control
she's been subtle about it Instagram
account tick tack room claims she posted
public apology when Mackenzie's video
resurfaced supposedly danke posted that
she was sorry acknowledged she needs to
grow and said she has made mistakes in
the past but this post is missing from
her Instagram account so it's possible
she posted it then decided to delete it
but as we all know it's almost
impossible to really get rid of things
once they're online
case in point Mackenzie's video that
kicked off this whole thing of course we
still have a ton of questions about the
situation will danke acknowledge what
happened between her and Maddie will she
remain a member of the hype house
despite all the drama we'll just have to
keep watching and refreshing our
Instagram feeds to find out do you think
Darian Kisan chess really bullied
Mackenzie Ziegler if so does she deserve
to be booted from the hype house or do
you think she should get a second chance
let us know your thoughts on the
situation in the comment section and
don't forget to click the subscribe
button and turn on your notifications
for more videos from us here at the
things we'll see you next time